you know as time has got on and when
overdue
doctor review became take two and from
then to now
the views on these videos have been
steadily going down
but i'm still gonna see it through
because this is who i am
this is where i stand where i stand
it's where i fall
how's that for a not really a joke
opening the doctor
falls the end of series 10.
and you know how
last time i said that going back to the
world enough in time
that i found more problems with it
and it kind of lost some
ground in my estimation
i just found more to love in the doctor
falls
i think in the past historically i have
placed uh world enough in time above dr
falls if i was looking at them as
individual things
but so help me
this thing is wonderful
top to bottom missy and the master
bill and what happened to her and her
conversion
nardole the doctor
all of it it is
phenomenal i kind of wish it was the
actual end of his run
instead of twice upon a time even though
i don't think twice upon a time
is bad it just feels weird
that this is building up to him being
done
and yet he's not done but that's more of
an issue for next time
so where do we start
well for starters it's a much better
cold open even though
it does have a slight jump forward in
time from where things actually pick up
because we have to pick up in the city
with
the master and missy being in absolute
control of everything or at least
thinking that they are now we do
actually get
kind of an explanation for what the
master was doing and why he was here
now it's debatable whether or not it's
canon
because what we get is we get the doctor
basically cold reading him saying
let me guess what happened and assuming
that the doctor's read is accurate which
might as well then what that means is
the master showed up here
maybe on purpose maybe by accident but
he got stuck
his his tardis busted and he's stuck
here
and he actually probably took over for a
while
but then given that he's lacking his
usual resources he's lacking his tardis
he doesn't have the taclophane to back
him up the people eventually
rebelled against him and that was why he
had to hide his face so
it comes an episode later but we have an
explanation for why he was
dressed as mr razor
around anyone who wasn't bill and why he
would have had
an existing alternate identity
established
so we get an explanation on that it's
still
a pure roaring coincidence that the
master happened to be stranded on a ship
that the doctor ended up on
but out of the things that i had
questions about from the previous
episode
i'm prepared to accept that one
coincidence
so because like the worst thing would
have been if it was some kind of
weird bizarre convoluted plan it's not
like which is the best thing for me
because i couldn't remember if we got an
explanation and i was dreading this
convoluted i've been waiting for you
plan explanation it's just not there the
implication is that the master's just
been cooling his heels around here and
the doctor just showed up
yeah i can work with that i like that
the doctor lays out the idea of
all the various cybermen that we've seen
and get referenced as what he calls
parallel evolution which is that
basically under the right circumstances
with the right amount of desperation
some version of the cybermen is just
what happens to the human race
when they're desperate enough which
honestly by that logic makes me wonder
would we count the taclophane
as a kind of cybermen just like
thematically if we're laying out that
idea
something to think about so the doctor
turns the table on
the master and missy they have to
abandon and go up to the
upper levels with bill in tow and the
doctor saying to her
i will fix this and they get up to
where we opened with bill carrying
him out and then later we have bill just
waking up
and i like that the show doesn't um
extend this for too long
but initially i i remember first time
watching this thingy oh
i guess he just fixed her that seemed a
little bit easy because she wakes up and
it's just bill
but then we start to see the way people
behave around her
and then before very long we get the
reveal no
she's still a cyber man and we and
we get like there's so many little
touches here that are the kinds of
things i got used to the show just not
bothering to do we get an explanation
for why bill is being so
good and and stubborn about fighting the
programming that's in her head
because the doctor references how long
and how fiercely she fought the monks
she basically had
however long the monks had taken over
earth that much time of continual
mental training to resist this kind of
stuff
so rather than going the clara route
she's just magical and amazing and the
best and
special because
we have an actual explanation as to why
she is able to resist this and even that
you can tell and it gets brought up
this is hard for her and she is going to
eventually
lose this fight and she actually has a
line that i had
completely forgotten that is almost kind
of my
key into a whole new understanding of
this episode
she says to the doctor i don't want to
live
if i can't be me anymore
you understand yeah
just the way that interaction was just
the thing that she said and the way
he answers makes it so clear that he
does understand
and it is this clinging
to everything that she is which is what
he's doing which actually
validates him fighting the regeneration
the way he does
actually from about the midpoint on
because we get hinted at that it's
starting to happen
well before we get to the climax of the
film and
him taking on board and fully and
understanding and embodying this idea of
i don't want to stop being who i am
and i think that's actually really core
to this doctor and a big part of my love
for this doctor i'm i'm planning to do a
deep dive on this
once i wrap up uh capaldi's tenure but
his
arc as a character the journey that he
goes on
during his time is
so impactful and meaningful to me
and this clinging to and this
understanding and
him reaffirming the idea of yeah i
don't want i'm not sure i want to keep
going if i can't be me
he's fought to be who he is right now
and he doesn't know who he'll be if he
regenerates
and he doesn't want to lose what he's
fought to become
i love all of that and i i
it breaks my heart and is so beautifully
written
that bill says to him you told me you
could fix me
did say that yes were you lying no
are you right wow
that is proper tragedy he
really thought that he could fix this
but he can't and he has to be honest and
admit that to her
that's crushing and
beautifully painful the doctor's entire
confrontation with missy and the master
oh that whole scene like every second of
it
is gold and again an affirmation of
who the doctor is as a whole but who
this doctor is
in specific who he is
what he stands for what he's here to do
and as much as i have gone on in the
past
about his whole thing where he goes i do
what i do because it's right
because it's decent
and above all it's kind
as much as i love that there's actually
a much more succinct
perfect summation of who the doctor is
and it's this you can't win i know
and
in that moment in that interaction
just making it plain i don't
care if i win
i will give a few people a fighting
chance for a little longer and it's the
right thing to do so i'm gonna do it
i love all of this so much and
capaldi puts his all
into that performance and that scene
especially but the whole
thing he does
phenomenal work in this
and missy and the master that's their
last scene with him they go off and
their scenes after that are only with
each other and they're still great
and that is done really well too and
there's something
perfectly suited to the idea that
a missy stabs him in the back
of course she does and he
hits her with the laser screwdriver says
she won't be able to regenerate after
this
which presumably she does but they
actually don't lock that down the
implication here is that she follows on
immediately
from john sim we actually don't know
that because she had flat out amidst
herself
i'm not sure i think so because
their being in the same place at the
same time has muddled up
time enough that things weren't
registering
right in terms of locking it away in her
memory
but after he does that to her
and she's dying and he's dying
that they just laugh about it
the master kills himself
and laughs about it in both incarnations
yeah yeah
that is awesome for this modern era
version of the master
it wouldn't have worked with earlier
versions of the master because honestly
the defining element of the master was
really
kind of the lengths he was prepared to
go to
to avoid death
that was a big part of what drove him i
mean that in the desire for
power and control but a lot of his
actions were driven by
a absolute terrified fear of dying
and so it you you really can only do
this
with more recent incarnations of the
master like john sim
like michelle gomez with these versions
of the master yeah i buy it
i buy it completely because he is
so spiteful and she
has just let go of so much hatred
they're just gonna laugh nardole's exit
is great
the argument that the doctor has with
him to basically convince him that he's
the one who needs to go with the
children
and the doctor has to be the one to stay
behind that is a brilliantly played
scene matt lucas really
wonderfully underplays most of that he
like he got
terrifically subtle with narnel as time
went on especially
in this episode that's all great there's
this awesome little moment
where the master is applying eyeliner
there's no real context for that moment
it just happens so i suppose you could
read it as he's learning how to put on
makeup because he knows he's going to be
missy later
i personally choose to read it as no he
just does that we've just
and he's always done that we've just
never watched him do it before i love
that
the melancholy in the doctor's voice
when he's
looking up dying no stars
i hope there'd be stars that hurts
wonderfully as well
and you know what i'm going to pick out
a line that a lot of people got
very uppity about when this thing aired
and it's this line from bill i'm usually
all about women
and then kind of people my own age
yeah glad you knew that
i remember so many people and maybe some
of them still do
i think i've just scared off most of
these kind of people from my channel
haha
don't miss you but i remember
so many people being like oh my god they
had to be like
hey did you know i'm a lesbian one more
time a woke agenda
cramming it down our throats no you
morons she's reaffirming her identity
her struggle this entire episode has
been
holding on to who she is
she's slowly losing that and saying she
would rather be dead than lose that
and in this moment with the doctor
reminding him of the first
two things he would have been aware of
about her
from their conversations together
she is reaffirming the base
of their interactions the base of his
understanding
of her identity she is reaffirming
who she is because that's what she's
been trying to do the whole episode
it's not going oh we got to be sure she
says she's a lesbian one more time which
gets reaffirmed later anyway with
heather
i i i said morons maybe that was a
little harsh to be fair i didn't quite
appreciate what that line was doing
but i always figured like even at the
time i'm like it's not doing what you
say it's doing
now i feel like i get what it's doing so
feel okay about that too i mentioned
heather
uh so before i get to that maybe i'll
like i'll do my one
kind of nitpick and then my overall
criticism
of the structure of these two parts
because like it it's not perfect for as
much as i've been gushing
because there's the upgrade of the
cybermen which like
makes total sense and it fits the fact
that
time is moving faster down below they
have time to upgrade
and that we get the more recent versions
of the cyberman that we've seen before
it still just makes the cybermen
kind of lose that creepy factor that
world enough in time gave them again
we have a little bit at the front end
with like the scarecrows
thing but like when they just show up
later and they're just getting blown up
left and right it's just the metal armor
again
it's a little bit of a letdown it's a
little bit of a disappointment
i i get why it's there and it makes
sense but it somehow
still feels a little deflating all the
same
but part of that has to do with the fact
that i
i floated this idea last time
i don't know how well i explained it i'm
going to try i'm going to take another
crack at it
i think that the two episodes
world enough in time and the dr falls
should truly have been three episodes
the story that is told over these two
episodes
should have been told over three what
should have happened was
the majority of the first episode should
have been dedicated
to missy trying to be the doctor
and the doctor monitoring them it should
have they should have extended that out
to be the majority of the episode
and have that end with bill
getting killed and getting taken down to
the lower floors
and then second episode should have been
basically what world enough in time was
up to the reveal of mr razor as the
master and then
honestly the doctor votes could
basically just be put up straight as it
is
but um mostly world enough in time
should have been split into two episodes
so that those two components could have
a little bit more room to breathe from
each other
and then this whole arc of
missy coming to terms with her identity
bill
losing her identity and then both of
those characters as well as the doctor
himself
all reaffirming who
they are and it still
lands but it could have landed better if
the story that's crammed into two
episodes could have had a little bit of
breathing room and stretch out over
three
i certainly would have taken this over
the monk three-parter as much as i love
extremists
this is where you should have dedicated
three episodes
so there's that now
heather and the return of heather and
the uh the whole idea of bringing back
the pilot
this was better than i remember but i
still have some
some niggles and or some uncertainties
about it it's better in that
my memory of it was that there was a lot
more emphasis on the idea that
their love brought her
back to save bill or something to that
like love
saves or love conquers all or whatever
uh
which this isn't and i
i actually don't necessarily have a
problem with that as a premise i like
i'm skeptical of it i won't lie but the
the
reason that idea bothered me was because
they barely knew
each other so the idea of their love was
so strong that now they must
live together i'm like what no but it
isn't really leaning on that
idea very hard at all so um
my memory kind of distorted how much
emphasis that had so that that was good
i do think that they there should have
been
somewhere along the line a reminder of
heaven
of heather not necessarily that she was
still out there because then we risk
turning heather into another mystery box
where like she's in the background of
things or
like we see shots from her perspective
and like or whatever
i i don't mean that i mean like i i feel
like there should have been more
pining of bill over the course of the
series as a whole
about what might have been or feeling
guilty about what happened to heather
because at this point we we do have 10
episodes in between when she's
introduced and when she comes back
and only two episodes that she appears
in so it is still
a little bit flimsy but the idea of
her saving bill by making her like
herself
actually went down for me much better
this time now there's a moment that
happens that i
am kind of of two minds on because i've
seen
other critics including ones that i
respect
really hammer on this moment as kind of
wrecking things a bit
but i'm not sure it does and that
is the moment where heather says that
she could turn bill human again
i can make you human again it's all just
atoms you can rearrange them any way you
like
can put you back home can make chips
i've seen this criticized in a way
because it
removes the tragedy
of bill's death because she could choose
to become
human again uh and that it kind of
takes the wind out of things that like
it could all be made perfect and makes
the death feel less substantive
i don't think it does i don't think
that's the reason that that line is
there i think the reason that line is
there
is because bill needs to
choose to go with heather
and if the choice is
travel with me or you just
die that's not really a choice
but if she has the option to become
human again that means that her choice
to not do that has value
and is legitimate and isn't coerced or
forced i will still grant it makes
heather as an entity very overpowered
in terms of what she's capable of doing
which was kind of an issue when
that went in that first episode anyway
like
what this fueled thing was even capable
of is
it's really op like that's still an
issue but
i think the reason that the whole idea
that she offers this to bill is to
let us know that bill choosing to travel
with her
is a choice freely made not because
well it's either that or death which is
what it might have
come across otherwise and the fact that
it is immediately followed up with
basically bill
accepting i didn't want to change
and i kind of have now but i'm still
fundamentally me
like my body's dead i'm now a weird
drippy fuel thing
but i'm still fundamentally me and
accepting that
change and then following that up
immediately with the doctor
saying i don't want to change again
never again fighting his regeneration
that feels really fitting i still think
he should have actually regenerated
at this point keep the speech from the
next one have him do that
but i think that should land here uh
instead we get the
teaser of him running into the first
doctor played by david bradley
which admittedly is a decent hook into
the
into the christmas special and i'll get
to that next week
but aside from a few small
points this is
phenomenal and i think
i think easily my favorite
finale of modern era doctor who
i think the only one that even comes
close might be
journey's end but
they don't get this good
this is so satisfying
and fulfilling and complete
and reaffirms everything i love about
this show
about these characters about this
incarnation of the doctor
in specific it's all
reaffirmed and it's amazing
the doctor falls
have you re-watched it lately what did
you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it
i have a patreon link in the description
i'll
maybe someday i'll get to put it up
there again i'm kind of giving up
because youtube is busted and won't tell
me why that won't work anymore
but if you are able to help me out on
the patreon there is
uh rewards at every tier things like
names in the credits
access to my discord uh getting to vote
in polls on future topics seeing my
docket for the upcoming months and
more there's also youtube memberships
which get you cool emojis and stickers
to get to use in the comments and in
live chats
as well as a few other perks take a look
at the options
this is my living and support through
things like the youtube memberships
and the patreon are what enable me to do
this
as my living so even if you're not able
to do that the likes to share subscribes
they
help me out but
no pressure at the end of the day
you're the council i'm only running the
meetings
and until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]